they're not defending the founding
principles because they're not governed
under those family principles
progressives have told us 100 years
they think the founding principles are
bunk they think the founding system of
government is bunk
they want a new one and they're going to
create it
they're kicking great american books out
of schools
i kid you not we were talking yesterday
about the book burning at target that
that you have uc berkeley professors
english professors
saying that we need to actually burn
books that suggest that we shouldn't
castrate children and
trans the kids well now a california
school district in l.a county
is removing huckleberry finn
to kill a mockingbird and of mice and
men
from their curriculum why they're
removing it because they say it's
racist or something they say it's
oppressive they say it's part of an
oppressive past
these are some of the greatest works of
american literature
certainly the most important works of
american literature for young adults to
read
being removed from the curriculum we've
been predicting this for years the left
told us oh you're crazy you're
hysterical
it's happening why is it happening in
part it's happening because the left
because the right rather refuses to
articulate a standard
when when we hear the media talking
about the erosion of norms and standards
when we hear about political correctness
which poses a new standard
the right gets backed into a corner
where we say hey i'm against censorship
i'm for free speech we use
bumper stickers and slogans but we fail
to articulate a standard ourselves
we want to be inclusive so we say oh you
can add your books to the curriculum you
can wear whatever you want to wear
the men can wear dresses whatever
but we just want to have our books too
the problem with this is
it's not doesn't persuade anybody and in
the case of education
education is by definition coercive
and exclusive there's only so many weeks
in the semester there's only
only so many books you can and if you
start adding in some crazy gender theory
book or some crazy
ibram kendi book about it you know how
awful white people are and we're a white
supremacist country or whatever
you have to remove a book and
the process you're seeing playing out in
these schools is okay we're going to
remove huck finn we're going to remove
to kill a mockingbird we're going to
remove
of mice and men it has nothing to do
with the intrinsic quality of these
books
all of which are much better than
anything ibram kindy has ever thought or
said in his entire life
but it's because those books uphold a
certain standard in a certain culture
and they come in a certain western
tradition and the left wants to get rid
of that we need to offer a standard we
need to say no you can't add your stupid
book
your your your book of lower quality
cannot come into the curriculum because
it will make our kids dumber
and we need to have good books in the
curriculum and we should only teach good
books
and not bad books because there's only
so much time and i want my kids to be
smart and i want your kids to be smart
i hope you enjoyed that short segment
from the michael knowles show be sure to
check out the full
episode linked in the description or
download the podcast
wherever you listen to podcasts
[Music]
you